you were uh a lead guitarist in the
metal band oh did i write that down for
something uh
what that did you uh what'd you do it
for the
the
the the performing was it the the pure
the the music of it was it just being a
rock star why'd you do it um
so we only ever played
two gigs
we we didn't last you know it wasn't a
very we weren't famous or anything like
that um but i
i was very into metal like it was my
entire identity sort of from the age of
16 to 23. the best metal band of all
time ah don't ask me that it's so hard
to answer
uh
ah
so i i know i had a long argument with
um
i'm a guitarist more like a classic rock
guitarist
so you know i've had friends who are
very big pantera fans and so there was
often arguments about
what's the better metal band metallica
versus pantera this is a more kind of
90s maybe discussion
um but i was always on the side of
metallica
both musically and in terms of
performance and the the depth of war and
lyrics and and so on so um but they were
basically everybody was against me
because if you're a true metal fan
i guess the idea goes is you can't
possibly be a metallica fan
i think metallica's pop it's just like
it's they sold out metallica are metal
like they they
were the
i mean again you can't say who was the
godfather of metal blah blah but like
they
were so groundbreaking
and so brilliant um
i mean you've named literally two of my
favorite bands like that's that when you
ask that question who are my favorites
like those were two that came up a third
one is children of bodum um who i just
think
they just take all the boxes for me um
yeah i don't know it's
nowadays like i kind of sort of feel
like a repulsion to the
i mean i was at myself like i'd be like
who do you prefer more come on who's
like no you have to rank him but it's
like this false zero sumness that's like
why they're so additive like there's no
conflict there
when people ask that kind of question
about anything movies
i feel like it's hard work
and it's unfair but it's it's you should
pick one yeah like and i that's actually
you know the same kind of it's like a
fear of a commitment people ask me
what's your favorite band it's like
but i you know it's good to pick exactly
and thank you for yeah thank you for the
tough question yeah uh well maybe not uh
no no no
a lot of people are listening um you
cannot just like what what is it
uh no it does it it's are you still into
metal uh funny enough i was listening to
a bunch before i came over here oh like
you do you use it for
like motivation yeah or get you in a
certain way yeah i was weirdly listening
to 80s hair metal before i came
does that count as metal i think i think
so it's it's like proto-metal and it's
happy it's optimistic happy proto-metal
um
yeah i mean amazing you know all these
genres bleed into each other um but yeah
sorry to answer your question about
guitar playing
my relationship with it was kind of
weird and that i was
deeply uncreative
um my objective would be to hear some
really hard technical solo and then
learn it memorize it and then play it
perfectly but i was
incapable of trying to write my own
music like the idea was just absolutely
terrifying um
uh but i was also just thinking i was
like it'd be kind of cool to actually
try
starting a band again and getting back
into it and right
but
it's scary that's scary i mean i i put
out some guitar playing just other
people's covers like i play comfortably
numb
on on the internet nice it's scary too
it's scary putting stuff out there
uh
and i had this similar kind of
fascination with technical playing both
on piano and guitar
you know uh one of the first
um
one of the reasons i started learning
guitar is the from ozzy osbourne mr
crowley solo and one of the first solos
i learned is that
um
and it's there's a beauty to it there's
a lot of beauty too
is there's some tapping but it's it's
just really fast
beautiful like arpeggios yeah arpeggios
yeah and but there's a melody that you
can hear through it but there's also
build up
it's a beautiful solo but it's also
technically just visually the way it
looks
when a person is watching you feel like
a rock star player
but it ultimately has to do with
technical
you
you're not developing the part of your
brain that i think
requires you to generate beautiful music
it is ultimately technical in nature and
so that took me a long time to
let go of that and just be able to write
music myself and
and that's a different
that's a different journey i think
i think that journey is a little bit
more inspired in the blues world for
example or improvisation is more valued
obviously in jails and so on but
um i i think ultimately it's a more
rewarding
journey because you get to
your relationship with the guitar then
becomes
a kind of escape
from the world where you can create
create i mean creating stuff is
uh and it's something you work with
because my relationship with my guitar
was like it was something to tame and
defeat
yeah
which was kind of what my whole
personality was about then like i was
just very like you know as i said like
very competitive very just like must
bend this thing to my will whereas
writing music is you were it's like a
dance you work with it
but i think because of the competitive
aspect for me at least that's still
there which creates anxiety about uh
playing publicly or all that kind of
stuff i think there's just like a harsh
self-criticism within the whole thing
it's really really it's it's really
tough to hear some of your stuff
i mean that it there's
there's certain things that feel really
personal and on top of that as we talked
about poker offline
there are certain things that you get to
certain height in your life and that
doesn't have to be very high but you get
to a certain height and then you put it
aside for a bit
and it's hard to return to it because
you remember being good
and it's hard to um like you being at a
very high level in poker it might be
hard for you to return to poker every
once in a while and enjoy it knowing
that you're just not as sharp as it used
to be because you're not doing it every
single day
that that's something i always wonder
with i mean even just like in chess with
kasparov some of these greats just
returning to it it's just it's almost
painful yes
yeah and i feel that way with guitar too
you know because i used to play like
every day a lot
so returning to it is painful because
like
it's like accepting the fact that this
whole ride is finite and
that you have you have a prime
there's a time when you're really good
and now it's over and now we're on a
different chapter of life i was like
but you can still you can still discover
joy within that process it's been tough
especially with some level of like
as people get to know you there's a and
people film stuff
you you don't have
the privacy of just sharing something
with a few people around you yeah
that's a beautiful privacy that that's
the point well the internet is
disappearing yeah that's a really good
point yeah
but all those pressures aside if you
really you can step up and
still enjoy the [ __ ] out of
a good musical performance
you